[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france a 24 y marinas sardiña
ya está conmigo en el estudio marina
bienvenida muy buena mañana de martes
hoy volvemos a hablar de la estrecha
relación entre el medio ambiente y por
supuesto nuestra salud porque un nuevo
estudio de la revista nature climate
change' se revela que más de la mitad de
las enfermedades patógenas humanas
conocidas pueden verse agravadas por el
cambio climático así errado la crisis
climática la emergencia global que
estamos viviendo puedes observar está en
un 58 por ciento las enfermedades
humanas con las que las personas entran
en contacto en todo el mundo esto va
desde virus comunes transmitidos por una
mala salubridad del agua por ejemplo
hasta enfermedades tan mortales como la
peste desde hace tiempo venimos hablando
de esta relación clima salud pero ahora
los científicos de investigadores han
revisado más de una década de
publicaciones científicas sobre todos
los patógenos conocidos para crear así
raúl un mapa de los riesgos agravados
por los peligros relacionados con la
crisis de climática de forma integrada
que esto es lo novedoso de
375 enfermedades humanas
218 se agravaron por el cambio climático
y es que este influye en más de 1000
vías de transmisión las inundaciones por
ejemplo raúl pueden propagar la
hepatitis no el aumento de las
temperaturas globales
prolonga la vida de los mosquitos que
transmiten por ejemplo la malaria estos
son algunos de los ejemplos los
investigadores se enfocaron en los 10
peligros relacionados con el clima por
el aumento de las emisiones de los gases
de efecto invernadero como sequías como
vemos aquí y sequías el aumento del
nivel del mar olas de calor y revisaron
los hallazgos históricos de más de 77
mil artículos de estas enfermedades
ligadas a estos fenómenos climáticos
creando así una base de datos de las
amenazas climáticas que son vías de
transmisión también de los patógenos y
de las enfermedades y que encontraron
raúl bueno encontraron que el mayor
número de estas enfermedades agravadas
por el cambio climático se produjo por
transmisión vectorial son enfermedades
humanas provocadas por bacterias
parásitos o virus que son transmitidas
por vectores por ejemplo mosquitos
moluscos acuático moluscos acuáticos
roedores o murciélagos
esto también lo veremos hablando desde
el copiloto 9 otro hallazgo está
relacionado con la amenaza climática la
mayoría estaban asociados al
calentamiento atmosférico
160 enfermedades marina y cómo influye
el clima en el riesgo de estos patógenos
que estamos hablando bueno los
científicos se encontraron cuatro formas
en las que los peligros climáticos
interactúan con los patógenos y los
humanos los uno que los acercan
modificando las gamas de animales y
organismos que pueden actuar como
vectores de enfermedades patógenas
peligrosas también acercan a las
personas a los patógenos por ejemplo las
olas de calor hacen que las personas
pasen más tiempo en el agua y este agua
puede estar contaminada con algunas
bacterias entonces se transmiten a los
humanos también aumentan los patógenos
puesto que tienen la oportunidad estos
patógenos de desarrollar nuevas
infraestructuras con los vectores por
ejemplo agua estancada mayor número de
mosquitos que pueden transmitir la
fiebre amarilla o que los virus se
vuelvan más resistentes al calor por el
aumento de a temperatura global que
estamos alertando ya desde hace mucho
tiempo también debilitan la capacidad
del cuerpo de las personas para hacer
frente a los patógenos por ejemplo
personas que viven en condiciones de
hacinamiento o con malas condiciones de
salubridad de potabilidad del agua pues
éstas son más propensas a enfermedades
porque padecen desnutrición entonces se
contagian más fácilmente enfermedades
como por ejemplo el cólera además de
examinar enfermedades infecciosas
novedoso es que ampliaron su búsqueda
sobre las no infecciosas como alergias o
asma esto es lo que dijo el estudio
encontramos más de 1000 vías diferentes
en las que la variedad de peligros
climáticos a través de diferentes tipos
de transmisión resultó en brotes de
enfermedades por una diversidad
taxonómica de patógenos la gran cantidad
de enfermedades patógenas y vías de
transmisión agravada por los peligros
climáticos revela la magnitud de la
amenaza para la salud humana que plantea
el cambio climático y la necesidad
urgente de tomar medidas agresivas para
mitigar las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero
la nota positiva raúl del estudio es que
algunas enfermedades 63 de 286
disminuyeron su propagación debido a
esta crisis climática puesto que los
virus no tenían las condiciones
adecuadas para sobrevivir o las personas
mejoraron su sistema inmunológico en
estas condiciones por ejemplo de calor
extremo se adaptaron claro bueno mariana
y tenemos la nota positiva vamos a
cambiar ahora de tema porque hoy es el
día mundial de los pueblos originarios y
la salud de estos mismos pueblos depende
también mucho de esta crisis climática
que estamos viviendo actualmente y la
destrucción de sus territorios como por
ejemplo la selva amazónica aquí en
nuestra américa latina-asia raúl no
queríamos olvidarnos de los pueblos
originarios y de cómo la crisis
climática está afectando a su salud
por ejemplo en la crisis climática
amenaza y agrava las condiciones de
salud de sus pueblos algo que ya hemos
visto con la pandemia sólo en américa
latina' raúl al menos 600.000 indígenas
se contagiaron y 15.000 fallecieron unos
datos que pues están muy desestimados
puesto que podrían ser muchísimo mayores
y esto que hizo que diezmó más sus
comunidades dejando patente las
desigualdades al acceso a la salud de
éstas
e indígenas los pueblos indígenas están
en extrema y constante vulnerabilidad
frente al avance de las enfermedades
infecciosas propagadas precisamente por
este cambio climático puesto que muchas
veces pues no cuentan con un sistema
inmunológico adecuado y no tienen el
acceso a tratamientos pese raúl a ser
ellos mismos quienes más protegen la
biodiversidad y el medio ambiente así es
marina gracias por esta pequeña
introducción digamos porque este tema lo
vamos a ampliar con nuestra segunda
mitad del día marina gracias
[Música]
hoy 9 de agosto se celebra el día
internacional